[Música]
bom vou falar um pouquinho do meu time
ele é um time diferente é nós somos o
primeiro tinha lgbt que de minas gerais
barbixas e pra começar a falar dele eu
preciso falar um pouquinho de mim da
minha história é é uma lembrança que eu
sempre fui uma criança assim como se diz
um pouco afeminada podia tocar o tcheco
estava lá não podia ver meu irmão mas
pelo que eu queria fazer uma uma trança
no cabelo dela ficava deslumbrado com a
quantidade de esmalte cores que minha
avó tinha né e isso nunca desviei o meu
olhar para o esporte é eu lembro que um
dos primeiros presentes que alguém na
vida foi do meu avô ele me deu uma bola
de futebol e ele me ensinou a chutar a
gente foi o divisor pra mim o brilho ali
eu fiquei assim gente eu quero ela tem
toda hora eu vou pra rua joga bola uma
rusga na bola
e olha a marca aquilo era o meu presente
favorito disparado e foi passando o
tempo e ainda continue sendo uma criança
mais afinada e eu fui reparando que eu
era diferente dos meus colegas e foi com
seis anos gente seis anos só quando se
ensina a criança conta de jeans enquanto
você tem 12 e eu atrelei essa lembrança
a essa memória de contar nos dedos e eu
com seis anos foi quando eu olhei meu
dedinho assim opa tem seis anos eu sou
diferente dos meus colegas porque
naquela época não sei como está hoje mas
pelo menos a minha escola era assim os
meninos chegaram as linhas seguidas a
quadrilha comigo e eu não queria chamar
nenhuma menina pra dançar comigo e eu
achava isso pois ninguém está falando de
uma menina e eu queria convidar o meu
crouch mirim da época né e né o tempo
foi passando e eu tive o futebol eo
esporte como refúgio para essa diferença
e eu joguei em vários times
é que eu passei eu joguei em várias
escolas que é porque eu participei
viajei joguei pela seleção de futebol de
campo da minha cidade e tem uma uma
frase que me falaram uma vez que escutei
na verdade né
e quem marcou muito foi o seguinte
gostava [ __ ] não é não gente joga bola
bem então a sociedade impõe duas
interpretações e muito maldosas até né
que o game não pode jogar futebol e se
ele sabe jogar futebol ele não joga ou
não joga bola bem né então eu cresci
continuando me esquivar de se desses
pensamentos essas atitudes vive uma vida
dupla de personagens até os 17 anos foi
aí que eu falei a parar com isso e mal
sabia eu que aos 24 e teria uma
felicidade enorme afundar sting é é a
rixa surgiu na partida uma uma idéia
fundada por times no rio de janeiro e
são paulo
e esse xis me ajudaram na divulgação
para que outras pessoas interessadas em
entrar em contato comigo e e pra gente
dar sequência aqui em minas gerais é é
aconteceu tudo muito rápido gente lembra
que foi uma quarta eu criei um grupo no
hati sap e gente no primeiro dia
apareceram 50 pessoas
eu fiquei perplexo não imaginava nunca
que chega esse número de pessoas e no
fim de semana o domingo acontece a nossa
primeira pelada e apareceram 21 pessoas
é a idéia era promover um espaço nessa
seguro onde as pessoas poderiam praticar
futebol lá tinham todos os tipos de
pessoas
assim que isso é o mais afinado mais
normativo sozinho todos os chips ea
idéia é promover um espaço que não tem
essa distinção não tenha preconceito não
tenha fala que machuco outro olhar ou
qualquer ato seja assim e é era pra ter
uma idéia uma pelada de um fim de semana
mas não a idéia
reto ea gente recebeu o primeiro convite
para participar do 1º campeonato né que
como foi comentado que foi o campeonato
nacional de futebol gay acham que eu
cheguei e que aconteceu no passado e eu
gosto de dizer que eu saí vitorioso e
por dois motivos ninguém esse campeonato
um foi porque saímos campeões e dois foi
porque eu tive finalmente a coragem de
sair do armário que eu sabia a dimensão
impacto que poderia atingir outras
pessoas com é fazenda tenha esse ato já
que estava à frente do team né
então com isso a gente cresceu numa
dimensão que a gente não imaginava nunca
de pela adin final de semana e tal ganho
um campeonato nacional é uma coisa todo
ea gente recebeu um novo convite que foi
em junho do ano passado e efeito pelo
mineirão é pra celebrar o orgulho lgbt
ea gente promoveram a partir deste tipo
ao nintendo miner on é ironicamente foi
é o nosso adversário também em junho do
mundo junto com a celebração de do
orgulho lgbt
e foi assim de uma alegria a gente que é
incomensurável não tem como não tem como
botar em palavras que eu senti lá foi
somente criança tá lá de de na televisão
os pessoal
efe a palavra você pode falar e jogando
lá sabe que tanta gente talentosa que já
passou lá eu tô lá cantando o hino
nacional
eu chorei tanto não tem ideias e não tem
idéia eu chorei pra caramba e com esse
feito
a gente conseguiu mais um mais uma
façanha né que foi nos tornarmos o
primeiro time lgbt que demais do brasil
é ocupar um estádio de futebol já
sediado uma copa do mundo né então só
lhe falar agora vem a parte em que tenho
que falar que é uma estatística não
muito feliz
mas eu acho interessante botar esse
assunto porque nem todo esse caminho de
conquistas e alegrias
sempre foram assim e sabemos como é o
futebol é é é é basta a gente olhar e
quantas pessoas enquanto os jogadores
são assumidos hoje em dia não pelo mundo
e eu tenho um exemplo muito triste é do
justin fashanu ele jogar jogava na liga
britânica da época em 1998 e ele assumiu
publicamente sua sexualidade e ele
escreveu uma carta se despedindo e
negando ter tido relações com uma menor
de idade 17 anos que foi acusado na
época e na carta ele afirmava que por
ele ser gay
as pessoas não iriam tratar da forma
justa e merecia e ele acabou cometendo
um atentado contra a própria vida né
então desse ato infeliz pra
estatisticamente falando a gente pode
ver que passados 15 anos hoje é esse
tabu vem caindo aos poucos sim e vários
atletas de várias outras modalidades
venci assumindo sem medo tem coragem de
falar não eu tenho orgulho de ser quem
sou né e é mas infelizmente no brasil no
brasil é o estatisticamente falando é
muito baixo ainda principalmente no
futebol com quantos jogadores de tim
assim com o nome renomado já falaram
abertamente sobre sua sexualidade mas
quase nenhum fogo fala sobre ea gente
não adianta achar que não existe pois
existe e só é brutalmente podem ter o
seu contrato rescindido por ser quem são
infelizmente então mas tendo em vista
toda essa visibilidade e impacto que a
gente tem a gente resolveu ampliar o
time e o que era um
hoje são 4 né não antes éramos apenas no
futebol
hoje são os temas do nosso caçula que o
time feminino de futebol
temos o handebol o vôlei ea corrida
temos ativos não tinham por volta de 200
pessoas mais ou menos e está a
conquistar troféus médio é reafirmar
nossa direção à sociedade é importante
sim mas tendo próximo da gente em
depoimentos os nossos jogadores é muito
mais recompensador
tem pessoas que foram expulsas de casa
tem pessoas que nos seus momentos de
tristeza profunda mesmo depressão já
tentaram é comentei alguma algum ato
contra a própria vida e viram a gente um
refúgio alguém que pra dar mão e isso
não tem prêmio que pague não tem é a
visibilidade que pague porque a gente
está falando de uma vida e toda a vida
deveria importar certo então o time
sempre teve essa premissa é de dar a mão
as pessoas e inclusive o gênero pra nós
também não importa pois vocês mulheres
também importa no futebol
acreditem é inclusive nosso treinador
que é maravilhosa que bravíssima é
mulher né então é tendo essa premissa de
ajudar as pessoas através de trabalhos
sociais e tudo
a gente só quer também mostrar um outro
lado do lgbt que é mal interpretado
não são as pessoas como quaisquer outras
humanos como quaisquer outros somos
alegres
temos o nosso lado amoroso também é e
temos competências técnicas
esportivamente falando também não tem
nada de errado e eu acredito é e em ser
quem somos
por isso a mensagem que gostaria de
deixar aqui seria que ansiosamente
espera um dia a gente espera um dia
mesmo não haver essa segregação entre
nós lgbt que mais e os héteros ou
qualquer outra sigla e orientação sexual
pois é diante do sporting
nós somos todos iguais né
obrigado 20
[Aplausos]
[Música]